Traductor: Jhohans Beltran
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Era el fin de 2016.
No sé qué estaban haciendo Uds.,
pero yo estaba pendiente de esto.
Este peliculón, si no lo vieron,
Dr. Strange, mírenla.
Pero la realidad es que
la mayoría de la gente en el mundo
estaba pendiente de lo que pasaba
en EE.UU.
EE.UU. estaba viviendo
un proceso de elecciones,
y lo que pasaba antes de eso
era que se veían estos números:
El 71 % para Hilary Clinton
por sobre Donald Trump.
Parecía que ganaba pero, en realidad,
terminó pasando esto.
Todos sabemos la historia, ganó Trump.
Pero, la vida siguió;
era abril de este año
y yo estaba pendiente
de una noticia que pasaba.
La NASA estaba trabajando
en este proyecto bastante raro,
un avión que atraviese
la barrera del sonido sin hacer ruido.
Bueno, y de repente me dicen:
"Sabes que Mark Zuckerberg
está siendo llamado al Senado a declarar,
aparentemente hubo filtración de datos,
y eso favoreció a Trump
para que fuera presidente.
Bueno, parecía raro,
pero esto estaba pasando.
Este personaje de Star Trek
se llama Data, no sé si...
Facebook es una empresa gigante,
y el poder que tiene sobre los datos,
sobre nuestro comportamiento,
es increíblemente grande.
Puso encima de un debate
sobre la privacidad de la información
en todas las mesas de Mirtha Legrand
del mundo se hablaba de esto;
la primera vez que pasaba una cosa así.
Entonces la gente empezó a pensar:
"¿Qué pasó con esto, qué hicieron?"
Bueno, los psicólogos dicen
que la personalidad es una mezcla
entre lo que pensamos, lo que sentimos
y lo que hacemos.
Y con cada clic que damos en Facebook
ellos nos conocen más y más.
Pero es ilegal que nos envíen anuncios
en función a esa personalidad.
Lo que aún no es ilegal es que
nos envíen anuncios
en función a nuestros intereses.
Por ejemplo, si le damos "me gusta"
a una película, o seguimos un artista.
Entonces, imagínense si hubiera
otra forma de generar esos avisos.
Hay una empresa
que se llama Cambridge Analytica,
que es especializada en análisis de datos
para campañas políticas,
que lo que hicieron fue
crear un algoritmo
que cree una personalidad
basada en los datos de Facebook.
Y parece que esto, según los expertos,
funciona muy bien.
De hecho, con 10 "me gusta"
que uno da en Facebook,
Facebook nos conoce mejor que
nuestros compañeros de trabajo,
Con 150 nos conoce mejor
que nuestros padres,
y con 300 mejor que nuestra pareja.
Ahora, Facebook tomó realmente
una muy mala decisión
con la forma en que manejaron
nuestros datos,
porque lo que hicieron fue,
de alguna manera,
utilizarlos para un fin que
no estábamos planeando, ¿no?
Nos imaginábamos algunos usos posibles,
pero, creo que no nos imaginábamos
lo que terminó pasando.
Entonces, nos da un poco de miedo,
porque usaron nuestras emociones
más íntimas,
para generar un provecho que no era
el que se suponía que podía pasar.
Y con todo esto,
para dar un caso práctico,
Donald Trump utilizó fuertemente
en su campaña el apoyo a las armas, ¿no?
a la portación de armas.
Entonces, imagínense que con esta prueba
que hicieron, que se llama
"La prueba de los 5 grandes",
basada en la psicología,
determinen algunos rasgos que dicen,
por ejemplo, que si somos
amigos del cambio, si somos extrovertidos,
si somos tímidos, si somos amables,
si somos de enojarnos fácilmente.
Con estas pruebas de "los 5 grandes"
que le llaman
crearon publicidades, crearon anuncios
que nos envían en forma dirigida
a nosotros.
Entonces, por ejemplo,
sí tenemos una personalidad
abierta al cambio,
y por ejemplo, podemos sentir
que nos pueden atacar desde afuera
pueden generar este tipo de anuncios,
no tan obvios como este,
pero sí que, inconscientemente,
nos trabajaran la cabeza.
Otro, por ejemplo, este anuncio
si sos una personalidad protectora
y tenés miedo a que le pueda pasar
algo a tu familia y al futuro,
una publicidad como esta otra.
Ahora, en esa época
había como dos grupos, ¿no?
O sea, había un grupo que decía,
bueno, yo le di a Facebook,
le di a Facebook todo lo que soy,
le di mi intimidad más preciada, ¿no?
le conté todo lo que hacía,
y las cosas más importantes.
Y otro grupo que estaba
del otro lado, y decía:
"Yo, bueno, era obvio
que iba a pasar esto,
Facebook es el Gran Hermano, Skynet,
y tienen toda la data, y bueno.
Creo que hay un punto medio
entre esas dos cosas.
Si puede ser que era obvio
que había muchos datos que tenían
y había unos usos comerciales
que se esperaban;
pero no era obvio que se usara
para lo que se terminó usando.
Ahora, con todo esto, ¿podemos decir
que los datos ganaron una elección?
Bueno, Cambridge Analytica dice que sí,
pero a ciencia cierta no sabemos
quién voto a quién
en función a los anuncios que vio.
Lo que si estamos seguros es que
esta campaña fue poco transparente
y que nos hizo replantearnos
las cosas que publicamos
en las redes sociales.
Seguramente a Uds. también les pasó.
Cuando hablamos de datos
les tengo que decir que
no siempre los datos que usamos
y los que compartimos
está mal hacerlo, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, este caso, en Londres
se viene trabajando hace muchos años
con la apertura de datos,
generar datos abiertos
para que miles de personas hagan casos;
casos como este, que les voy a contar,
donde el Gobierno, bueno,
cuando llega tarde un tren
que no debe pasar muy seguido,
le devuelve el valor del boleto
a las personas.
Nadie reclamaba, la plata quedaba ahí
y hubo un emprendedor, que
se le prendió la lamparita, y dijo:
"¿Por qué no hacemos algo con esto?"
El tipo agarró y creó una plataforma
donde los usuarios se registran
con sus datos de la tarjeta,
la SUBE de Londres, digamos.
Cargan sus datos,
y cuando el tren llega tarde,
y ellos tienen el registro de la hora
que debería haber llegado,
lo comparan con la hora
que se subió esa persona,
y si hay una devolución,
se la envían directamente.
O sea, que cobrás solamente
porque llegó tarde el tren.
De esta forma, el emprendedor
hizo unas libras, ¿no?
Se quedó con unos billetes en la mano,
porque se puede hacer plata
y hacer el bien al mismo tiempo
por supuesto.
El tren está feliz porque
está auditado por este sistema,
o sea, funciona cada vez mejor
gracias a que la gente
hace este tipo de controles.
Y las personas que los usan están felices,
se benefician con el dinero
del boleto reintegrado
y encima, con un servicio cada vez mejor.
Ahora, no hace falta ser
un capo emprendedor
como este muchacho.
No hace falta querer ser presidente
o ser dueño de una corporación
para usar datos y para tomar decisiones.
A mí me pasó un montón de veces, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, a los 12 años
estaba viendo esta película,
no sé si la vieron,
"Juegos de Guerra".
Uds. son muy jóvenes todos.
"Juegos de Guerra" era un chico
que estaba en la casa
y le había ido mal en una materia,
se metió a hackear con esa tecnología
y terminó metiéndose en el pentágono, ¿no?
Yo estaba viendo esa película
a los 12 años;
a esa edad también bailaba folclore.
Les tengo que confesar,
no le cuenten a nadie
pero aparentemente
no era muy bueno bailando, ¿no?
y un día estaba en mi casa,
viendo la película
y viene mi vieja y me dice:
"Fredi, mira, yo te quiero mucho,
te quiero decir algo,
pero no sos bueno bailando folclore.
Y lo bueno es que esos ARS 100
que usamos en esas clases
te las podemos dar
para que hagas lo que quieras".
Bueno, yo dije,
primero me sequé las lágrimas,
me recompuse, y dije:
"Bueno, me gusta mucho la computación,
quiero ser un hacker como este muchacho,
quiero ser como él".
Me metí a los institutos de computación,
y ahí aprendí este apasionante e increíble
mundo de la tecnología de los 90, ¿no?
Yo me volvía loco con esto,
pasaba horas jugando.
Y después de eso me dediqué
toda la vida a la tecnología,
a aprender, a enseñar
a trabajar con la tecnología.
Y desde ese momento lo hago.
También intento buscar la manera
de usar la tecnología
con un uso diferente,
hackearla digamos, ¿no?
Tradicionalmente uno piensa
que algo se crea para una cosa,
pero se puede dar un uso distinto.
Y una vez estaba
en una actividad de voluntariado,
no sé si algunos habrán hecho,
están buenísimos.
estábamos pintando un colegio,
y estaba con dos compañeros de trabajo,
un físico, un ingeniero, dos cracks,
un talento terrible.
Estaban pintando una reja,
y lo hacía terriblemente mal, ¿no?
No sabían pintar,
la pintaban dos veces igual,
se peleaban por los colores.
Le ponían onda, pero eran malísimos.
Entonces, yo pensé:
"Por qué le damos todo nuestro talento
a las empresas a las que trabajamos,
y cuando le estamos dando
algo a la sociedad,
le damos lo que peor hacemos.
Y con esa reflexión, profunda, ¿no?
hicimos uno de los proyectos este año,
apalancados en esta iniciativa global
que se llama Data for Good.
Data for Good es una iniciativa
que busca usar ciencia y datos,
el poder de los datos, para impactar
positivamente las vidas de las personas.
Hicimos un proyecto que impactó
más de 3 millones de personas,
porque en todo el país
hay unos 240 000 barrios populares
que son los barrios donde vive gente
que no tienen un certificado que
habilita ese domicilio como válido.
Entonces, no pueden pedir un servicio,
o no pueden anotar sus hijos al colegio.
Eso pasa en todo el país.
Hay un montón de organizaciones
trabajando hace dos años más o menos,
se tardaron casi dos años en relevar
casa por casa
en toda la geografía vasta
que tiene nuestro país.
E hicieron un relevamiento increíble
para poder hacer puntos de entrega
de estos certificados.
Para que se junte la gente
con el certificado
y que puedan tener ese domicilio válido.
Eso es bastante complejo, ¿no?
porque el país es muy grande.
Entonces, nos pidieron
cómo podemos mejorar el proceso de eso.
Creamos un algoritmo
usando técnicas de ciencia de datos
para optimizar esos puntos de entrega,
que en cada barrio se haga uno,
y que las familias tengan
que caminar lo menos posible
Esta es la primera familia que obtuvo
el certificado de vivienda en Bariloche,
el primero de país:
con eso pudo conectar la luz en su casa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Con esto buscamos
que estas organizaciones argentinas
tengan el mismo poder de decisión
que tienen,
gracias a las herramientas
de análisis de datos,
que tienen las empresas de Silicon Valley,
es realmente el mismo.
Para que puedan hacer mejor
lo que hacen mejor.
Nosotros visualizamos un futuro
donde estas organizaciones,
que enfrentan estos problemas,
tengan el mismo nivel de acceso
al análisis avanzado de datos
que tienen las grandes corporaciones.
Los datos, la tecnología,
la información está ahí para la usemos.
Cualquiera de Uds.
puede cambiar su vida,
pueden emprender
y hacer un cambio en la realidad,
y las grandes corporaciones
pueden cambiar el mundo.
¿Uds. que van a hacer
con los datos que tienen,
que decisiones van a tomar?
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)